merci merci madame la présidente madame
la première ministre mes chers collègues
100 euros pour faire un plein 2000 euros
pour remplir la cuve de fuel 200 euros
de plus par mois pour faire les courses
l'inflation galopante et les taxes
plombe le pouvoir d'achat des français
avec des spéculateurs sans scrupules qui
se gave au passage c'est à croire
d'ailleurs que tout se fabrique en
ukraine et en russie madame la première
ministre le budget des ménages explose
et il est temps d'agir vite et fort en
revalorisant les pensions des retraités
et des personnes en situation de
handicap en faveur desquels nous nous
battons vous le savez depuis des mois
pour revaloriser lâche l'allocation
adulte handicapé en baissant les charges
comme la csg pour les retraités les
salariés et les indépendants et faire
ainsi d'une pierre deux coups à rouvrir
valorisant le travail car ils manquent
des bras partout en neutralisant le prix
des carburants à 1 euro 50 à la pompe à
tous ceux qui ont besoin de leur voiture
au quotidien c'est 80 % des français le
savent un litre de carburant c'est 60%
de taxes alors madame la première
ministre combien de temps encore allez
vous pomper les milliards d'euros sur le
dos des phrasés
[Applaudissements]